[Music]
spring in chris sims pro football talk
live co-host and of course an analyst
for nbc sunday night football what was
your reaction to carson palmer
mentioning mike tomlin's name as a
possible usc head coach candidate
well i was surprised to hear it i mean
anytime you hear carson palmer talk
about usc of course you you perk up a
little bit he did win the heisman he of
course knows some of the the big players
at that school as far as you know the
the guys that are tossing around the
ideas of who should
who should coach for their team um mike
tomlin
he'd be i can't ever envision him making
that move i can't just because i think
he's so ingrained in the nfl and that
way of life but i do think he could be
successful in college he's the best
communicator i've ever been around or at
least one of the best that's for sure
you know he was in tampa one of the
secondary coaches uh the secondary coach
when i was there and he's a great
motivator he really understands how to
connect to people there's no excuses or
bs and from that standpoint and of
course knows football yeah i think he
could do it for sure but uh i i just
don't see it happening i think he likes
nfl head coach life and likes being the
head coach of the steelers either those
two teams last night any good
uh i mean the seahawks are not they're
not that's you know again they'll
continue to play tough and compete but
like what what is there to be what's
there to look at to be good i mean on
defense okay the two safeties are good
you know i mean bobby wagner's you know
solid still but getting up there in
years the jordan brooks linebacker good
nobody on the d-line you're going oh wow
you better game plan to stop that guy
nothing no corner to worry about and
then the offense offensive line average
you know running back chris carson not
healthy and
i mean with russell wilson out the best
thing they got going for their team is
dk metcalf and tyler lockett and it's
like they almost go out of their way not
to give them the ball i don't understand
that so that's crazy i do give a little
hope for new orleans i do because
i think their defense is legit as you
saw last night and that will continue
but the offensive line can be
overpowering the past game's a work in
progress jamis is a work in progress
right now and so are the receivers to go
along with it so it's kind of a double
whammy and i think you know with sean
payton i have faith in him i give them
hope to be
you know i think they can get in the
playoffs i pick them to be in the
playoffs and be a pain in the butt once
they get in there if they can just get
the offense rolling a little bit maybe
get michael thomas back that would help
okay wait a minute how long is jameis
winston a work in progress
well he's a work in progress for
like
like life in the nfl away from what he
did in tampa i mean this is yeah no in
the christmas yeah i i get it you know
but you know he got into a team there
where he of course he did some good
things and we know he did a lot of
stupid things there too
but also they never really reigned him
in so he's trying to rewire the robot
here a little bit as far as just
protecting the football doing the right
thing you know hey they're they're
winning football games it hasn't been
pretty yeah he misses some throws but
we're seeing the stupid plays disappear
i think that's a positive and again like
you know you saw last night hey threw a
great goal ball down the right side than
to kenny stills i mean i don't know it's
right in two hands catch it a post route
down the middle early on in the game i
don't know what the hell the traequan
smith was doing so you know they're not
real talented at that position he needs
a little help there and yeah he's not
perfect within that offense and i think
sean payton too dan to your point is is
bringing him along slowly he doesn't
want to make it all about him and then
him revert back to the guy he used to be
and screw things up and screw things up
for their football team all right if
you're russell wilson
yeah do you want to stay in seattle
yeah that's a uh florio and i spent a
good portion of the show today talking
about this topic because
i mean of course he made waves on your
show last year and i know people behind
the scenes who have talked to russell
wilson
he wants to be
in a josh allen patrick mahomes type
offense
seattle shows no signs of doing that i
mean it's still yeah they got shane
waldron from the rams it's still
the same seattle look we're gonna run
the ball we're gonna run the ball we're
gonna play defense and we just hope to
have a one score game in the fourth
quarter oh great that's fun coach that's
what we're hoping for just a one score
game in the fourth quarter and then you
know russell pulls off magic so he's got
to be thinking about it a little bit or
worried about it to a degree because i
don't know if it's in their
realm realm of
you know realistic possibilities that
pete carroll will let them change on
offense and become anything else other
than what we've seen really the the
whole era he's been there but i wonder
does seattle want to keep him and does
russ want to stay there
because they could be two different
answers there
and and maybe they want to i mean pete
is the oldest coach in the nfl does he
right does he want to sit here and do
what belichick is trying to do in in new
england
yeah i i i don't know i mean that's
going to be a that's going to be a big
big question i i think we're
i would not be shocked if we're headed
towards this type of conversation when
the off season's over where russell's
just like hey listen it's coming to an
end you guys want to play defense and
run the ball and that's cool and i
respect it but you know i'd like to
broaden my horizons a little bit and get
into three four wides shotgun let me let
the game be about me and me applying the
pressure on defenses and play through
that instead of let's play through the
running game and defense and then when
we're down by four in the fourth quarter
just ask me to make magic happen that's
a hard way to live and that's what he's
been doing there for a while talking to
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host and analyst for nbc sunday night
football according to espn's dan
graziano the cleveland browns
are looking at an offer contract offer
with baker mayfield
and uh
it would pay him in the mid to high 30
million dollars per year to stick around
so maybe an 80 offer of what the going
rate would be for a
good to elite quarterback there it's not
josh allen money it's not patrick holmes
or deshaun watson if you're baker
do you
i don't know what kind of leverage he
has chris
sure i mean he's not dak prescott that
president dak passed on this bet on
himself even got injured and still ended
up with his paycheck
uh what would you do if you're baker
mayfield if that is the offer to stay
yeah i mean and daki you know even
before the injury and up to that played
at a much higher level than people kind
of wanted to give him credit for it now
you know now everybody's like whoa look
how good he is and it's like no he was
good all along they've just gotten
better as a football team finally here
i would take it if i'm baker mayfield i
mean i think your points right you know
again what's the leverage that's out
there do you really want to play that
game you're in a pretty good spot you
were the number one pick they believe in
you you know there's something to be
said about that and hey you got a team
there that's you know of course it is
good hey they're disappointing they're
four and three they're one of the better
rosters in football but still like
fixable and a lot of talent on both
sides of the ball to where
man you know the grass isn't always
greener on the other side of the fence i
would take that up on him and i think
that's a solid offer by the browns too
because you said it right i mean he's
he's not one of the five best
quarterbacks that's for sure he's not in
that class and to me like this is where
the nfl and front office guys got to
change a little bit it can't always be
next guy up he gets more money no
absolutely not at some point they got to
draw a line in the sand or are we going
to have keep having jared goff issues
with some of these quarterbacks where
they're going to go what the hell are we
thinking two or three years down the
road he's better than jared goff i'm not
trying to say that but of course it's
been a little bit of a roller coaster
with his play you know through his
career uh so i would take it if i'm him
i i would if i'm the browns i wait till
the end of the year let's just see you
know you got the shoulder you're going
to have surgery
um
you know i you're going to have other
guys available you know jimmy garoppolo
may be available russell wilson maybe
aaron rodgers you make a run ahead like
i you know hear you before i sign up
baker mayfield and then i realized oh my
god we we could have had they wanted
russell wilson a couple of years ago yes
they did because seattle from what i'm
told was going to take josh allen
and the browns were going to take
russell wilson they were going to have a
trade between you know those two teams
so yeah i know russ was open to that
cleveland wanted him and seattle was
ready to move on from russell wilson and
get john you imagine if that happened
well i know i know i was one of the guys
that kind of broke that that story there
and you know but yeah i mean that's
that's it's uh it's
it would be amazing it really would be i
mean yeah it would it's of course at
that time you didn't know what josh
allen was gonna be you knew wilson was
certainly one of the best quarterbacks
in football i'm sure
you know i don't i don't know i don't
know who got cold feet in that
conversation or where that got slowed
down there uh but either way the browns
went with baker mayfield and hey the way
they play i mean
they're not it's not it doesn't have to
be quarterback centric right that's you
know again the greatness of the browns
is their run game it's the best
offensive line in football it's the best
it's the most well-coached offensive
line in football and with those two
running backs healthy damn they're good
they really are and maybe they just look
at it too like okay yeah maybe you could
get rogers or wilson or somebody like
that in the off season but there's no
guarantee that happens
and uh maybe that opens up a can of the
worms they don't want to deal with
either i i gotta wrap my head around it
more but
i understand them staying with baker
mayfield he is their guy he has shown
positive signs and played really well at
points it's just every time i'm sitting
there ready to go man he's got it he's
awesome he looks good he puts two or
three games together where i go what the
hell i'm not sure if he does got it and
we're back to you know the same
conversation and you know who knows
better than them and hopefully they do
know better than us he's a good
quarterback with great marketing i mean
that's
sure that that's what it comes down to
he he appears to be a star
even though he's not he doesn't play
like a star but but he has that's right
he has that presence um a couple other
things here
yeah your advice for the kansas city
chiefs and patrick mahomes would be
well i mean uh you know again nothing
new that you haven't heard you know of
course they got to show the ability to
be able to be boring and execute and go
on breeze and brady type drives that we
used to see with new england and the
saints where it's 12 plays 85 yards and
and bore some teams to where they get up
there and start to play them differently
to go whoa we can't just die a slow
death or they're just gonna surgically
destroy us all game but but in a bigger
picture too
you know i've broken this down on my
podcast a few times and it reared its
ugly head because i watched the film in
this game this past week yesterday
mahomes played his worst game as a pro
yeah on sunday hands down there's no
doubt about it i i mean he missed some
reads where i'd go there's the first
read throw it he's kind of looking at
the rush his pocket presence is really i
think the most concerning thing right
now he's leaving the pocket way too
early at times he's got to watch some
dan marino tom brady
joe burrow film and watch how they
manipulate and move within the pocket
you know right now
i think he got into some bad habits and
i don't know this but i'm just this is
me watching you know being johnny nerd
who watches football all the time i
think last year got him in some bad
habits they couldn't protect him the
last seven or eight weeks of the year so
he was always floating around because he
knew man somebody's gonna come free i
gotta buy myself some time and this year
i mean there's there's a bunch of plays
in the game the other day where i go
it's it's perfect where are you going
people are open the interception he's
got tyree killed down the left sideline
he's i mean it's it's it's what you want
but for some reason he leaves the pocket
and the second reads open too and it's
just a little of that right now to where
he's not playing as true to form to the
position as he's capable and he needs to
fix it because the offense is gonna have
to carry them the defense isn't gonna
get much better they're built for the
offense to carry them expensive o-line
high-priced receiver high-priced tight
end high-priced quarterback it's on them
to put the pressure on opposing teams
and go off of that
it feels like we were looking at every
team in the afc north except for the
cincinnati bengals so you said okay ben
coming back they draft a running back
maybe they got one more year of magic oh
the browns are loaded you know they're
super bowl contenders oh the ravens they
just beat the chargers they might have
the mvp lamar jackson then all of a
sudden
cincinnati comes to baltimore now you
can say trap game but it's a divisional
game so i'm not buying it's a trap game
um
are you sold on the bengals being the
best team in the afc north or at least a
playoff team well yeah i'm i'm sold on
them being on the playoff conversation
and that type of team
again yeah i didn't see this coming from
the bengals i mean i'm not going to lie
but i will say for the last like two
weeks and i think football night in
america two sundays ago i said like
listen
stop everybody waiting for like the
floor to fall out here it's not they're
here to stay this is they're not gonna
fall apart as a football team that's not
going to happen and i'm not saying they
go to the playoffs but they're playing
off caliber for sure you know you look
at their team they're offensive line
they're really big in the interior
they've gotten a little bit better every
week you got a star running back and
mixing they have a good little offensive
system where they draw up a few tricks
every now and every week just to add to
that and of course jamar chases he's
uncoverable i mean he really is he's in
the conversation for the best receiver
in football already as a rookie if you
play one-on-one your butt's going to get
burned that's just plain and simple let
alone they got other guys in the passing
tree there that are good too and
defensively dan they got two big guys in
the middle and ogun joby and dj reader
three athletic linebackers two real good
safeties and some good cover corners it
wasn't a mistake they were toe-to-toe
with the green bay packers a few weeks
ago they're they're that caliber of a
team and i think they're gonna be here
to stay for for the rest of the year
uh good to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time thank you chris
thank you dan say hi to all those idiots
back there with you okay hey hey chris
says hey hi idiots hi chris yeah
hi
that's uh chris sims pro football talk
live co-host nbc sunday night football
analyst